we have two copies of six different
figures right over here and I want to
think about which of these figures are
going to be unchanged if I were to
rotate it 180 degrees so let's do two
examples of that so I have two copies of
this square if I were to take one of
these copies and rotated 180 degrees so
let me show you what that looks like
we're going to rotate around its center
180 degrees we're going to rotate around
the center so this is it
so we're rotating it that's rotated 90
degrees and then we've rotated 180
degrees and notice the figure looks
exactly the same
this one the square is unchanged by 180
degree rotation now what about this
trapezoid right over here let's think
about what happens when it's rotated by
180 degrees so that is 90 degrees and
180 degrees so this has now been changed
now I have the short side or the show I
have my basis short and my top is long
before my base was long and my top was
short so when I rotated 180 degrees I
didn't get to the exact same figure I
have essentially an upside down version
of it so what I want to do for the rest
of these is pause the video and think
about which of these will be unchanged
in which of them well will be changed
when you rotate by 180 degrees so let's
look at the star thing and one way that
my brain visualizes it imagine the
center that's what we're rotating around
and then if you rotate 180 degrees
imagine any point say this point
relative to the center if you were to
rotate it 90 degrees you would get over
here and then if you rotate 180 degrees
you go over here you go on the opposite
side of the center from where it is so
from that point to the center you keep
going that same distance you'll end up
right over there so this one looks like
it won't be changed but let's verify it
so we're going to rotate 90 degrees and
then we have 180 degrees it is unchanged
now let's look at this parallelogram
right over here
so it's Center if we think about its
center where my where my cursor is right
now think about this point the distance
between that point and the center if we
were to keep going that same distance
again you would get to that point
likewise the distrophy were to go that
same distance again you would get to
that
so it seems like that point would end up
there that point would end up there and
vice versa so I think this one will be
unchanged by rotation so let's verify it
so you go 90 degrees and then you go 180
degrees or I should say it will be
unchanged by a rotation of 180 degrees
around its center we got the same figure
now let's think about this triangle so
if you think about the center of the
figure let's say the center of the
figure is right around right around here
if you take this point go to the center
of the figure and then go that distance
again you end up in a place where
there's no point right now so that point
is going to end up there this point is
going to end up there this point is
going to end up here so you're not going
to have the same figure anymore and so
we can rotate it to verify so that's
rotated 90 degrees and then that's
rotated 180 degrees so we've kind of
turned this thing on its side it is not
the same thing now let's think about
this figure right over here
well this figure if you rotate 180
degrees this point is now going to be
down here and this point is going to be
up here so you're going to make
essentially is going to be an upside
down version of the same kite and we can
view that we can visualize that now so
it's going to be different but let's
just show it so that is 100 and this is
90 degrees and now this is 100 and 180
degrees if it if it was actually
symmetric if it actually was symmetric
about about the horizontal axis then we
would have a different scenario we would
have a different scenario with this
thing right over here if it was some
type of a parallelogram or a rhombus or
something like that then this could have
been more interesting but in this
situation in this situation if it was
just kind of a more symmetrical diamond
shape than we would have then the trend
this rotation would not have affected it
but this one clearly did